the minaret of Mosul's great mosque
still stands well fighters from the
Islamic state cling to the prize as the
place where their Caliphate was once
declared abu bakr al baghdadi declared
himself caliph the Prophet Muhammad's
heir at the head of a new Islamic empire
well Helen was slimming yg1
but the way I know porn well I know
Allah but now that caliphates back is
being broken
it was the capture of mosul of this city
that allowed a pretty much unknown
extremist jihadi group to suddenly
evolve into the preeminent radical
franchise completely eclipsing al-qaida
and it was the declaration of the
Caliphate in the mosque just a few
hundred yards down the road where the
fighting continues to be intense that
was the moment when this place this new
state entity became a magnet for jihadi
fighters from around the world they
stormed the Syrian Iraqi border they
used broadcasters of their atrocities to
turn the internet into a tool of terror
this is just some of the group began by
seizing territory in Syria four years
ago back then calling itself the Islamic
state in Iraq and the Levant it
swallowed vast tracts of the Sunni
heartland in Syria and Iraq
so by 2014 it controlled huge
populations along the Tigris and
Euphrates rivers and included Mosul
where the Caliphate was proclaimed but
to counter attack by anti Caliphate
forces has systematically pushed it back
leaving just a few hundred fighters
holding on in the old city of Mosul if
they declared the Caliphate after
capturing muslin losing muscle would
kind of go back against that declaration
to some extent and because of that they
view it as an existential sort of
sort of fight for locals like Bashir
there is hope that this is indeed the
end of the caliphate because Isis lived
in the school that he guarded and built
suicide trucks across the street matawan
she here now
Ziya ad hominem at humble look I saw
myself as a pilot could she wrestle
citizens are returning nervously to
their homes near the frontline but a
little further back war seems almost
distant when they first captured this
city Islamic state enjoyed an immediate
financial bonanza the central bank had
four hundred million dollars in cash in
it but there's two million people here
and they represented an incredibly
important resource there were
opportunities for kidnapping for
extortion for the sale of Antiquities
but above all for taxation so that by
2014 the state had net revenues of about
two billion dollars and that has over
the last year and a half crashed down to
800 million last year Iraqi officers
though are in no doubt that the
Caliphate is dead within mother : unless
well below early an deficit thought I'm
gonna move in this book dr. bottom - dad
it's ooh really I'm how other talk dr.
Bolivar ACMA Celia wanna talk about a
more Hardy at home Camila little - / -
victory in Mosul may spell the end of
the idea of the caliphate but not of the
ideology that brought it to life
the problem with Isis is it's not just a
military force it's also based on a
certain ideology and it's also based on
a certain sectarian division both of
which could reoccur if we don't get the
politics of the the retaking of Mosul
right in other words the heirs of the
Caliphate may yet arise even from this
shattered landscape Sam Kiley Sky News
Mosul